>> A PHONE CALL FROM HOME...
>> OH, NO!
>> BROUGHT JAEL THE TRAGIC NEWS
OF A FRIEND'S DEATH.
>> SHE'S NOT HERE ANYMORE.
>> BUT YOU'RE GONNA BE OKAY.
>> AND EVERYONE
BARED THEIR SKIN
AT THE PHOTO SHOOT.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT, JAY?
I THINK I'M MORE COMFORTABLE
NAKED.
>> BUT CASSANDRA'S PHOTO
FAILED TO DELIVER.
>> YOU HEARD THE JUDGING PANEL--
SILENCE.
>> AND SHE WAS SENT HOME.
TEN GIRLS REMAIN.
WHO WILL BE ELIMINATED TONIGHT?
(drumroll)
>> YOU WANT TO BE ON TOP?
♪♪
>> I NEVER WANT TO BE
DOWN AT THE BOTTOM EVER AGAIN.
I CAN'T HANDLE THAT.
>> WELL, THEY TOLD ME
I'M NOT A MODEL.
>> WHEN'D THEY SAY THAT?
>> SHE WAS LIKE,
"I SEE SUCH A PRETTY GIRL,
BUT... THE JUDGES DON'T THINK
THAT YOU'RE A MODEL."
I LEFT A VERY GOOD SCHOOL
TO COME HERE AND BE ON
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL."
I GO TO DARTMOUTH,
AND I'M NOT ON FINANCIAL AID,
SO THAT'S $9,000
THAT I'M GONNA BE IN THE HOLE
TO MY FATHER.
SO IF YOU DON'T THINK
THAT I LOOK OR ACT LIKE A MODEL,
I'M GONNA MAKE YOU KNOW
THAT I'M A MODEL.
>> TYRA MAIL!
>> "STRIKE A POSE,
AS IF THERE'S NOTHING TO IT.
LOVE, TYRA."
♪♪
>> MY LITTLE GRASSHOPPER.
>> COME ON, WE GOTTA DO IT
IN THE MIRROR SO I CAN SEE.
>> OKAY.
I KNOW THAT JAEL'S PRETTY UPSET,
YOU KNOW,
ABOUT LOSING HER FRIEND.
BUT I THOUGHT THAT, YOU KNOW,
IF I TAUGHT HER A DANCE,
IT'D TAKE HER MIND OFF OF IT
A LITTLE BIT.
ONE, TWO, THREE, FOUR.
>> MY FRIEND DIED,
BUT I DON'T FEEL ALONE
GOING THROUGH THIS.
I FEEL REALLY FORTUNATE
TO, LIKE,
HAVE FRIENDS IN THE HOUSE.
FUN!
>> (speaks indistinctly)
HEY, DON'T SHOW THE GIRLS.
>> (both speaking indistinctly)
>> I FEEL LIKE
A LOT OF THE GIRLS IN THE HOUSE
DON'T UNDERSTAND ME.
LIKE, THEY'RE JUST LOOKING
FOR WAYS TO BE OFFENDED BY ME.
I DON'T KNOW WHY.
I FEEL LIKE THEY...
JUST DON'T LIKE ME.
>> THIS MORNING
IS A BRAND-NEW MORNING FOR ME.
I WOKE UP AND I THOUGHT,
YOU KNOW WHAT, RENEE?
YOU'VE BEEN GETTING INTO IT
WITH ALL THE GIRLS
QUITE A LOT...
I HAVE BEEN NOTHING BUT NICE TO
YOU,
NOTHING BUT GENUINE TO YOU.
DON'T--DON'T GET DEFENSIVE.
YOU--YOU WANT ME NOT TO STATE MY
OPINIONS?
I WANNA WIN THIS.
I'M NOT GONNA WIN IT
WITH A BITCHY ATTITUDE,
SO I GOTTA STOP BEING MEAN.
SO I'M MAKING A CHANGE.
>> OW!
>> JAEL?
>> WHAT?
>> I HAVE SOMETHING FOR YOU.
>> AND I DON'T WANT YOU TO TAKE
OFFENSE TO IT,
'CAUSE I DON'T MEAN IT
OFFENSIVELY.
>> WHAT?
NOW WHAT ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT,
"OFFENSIVELY"?
>> WELL, 'CAUSE IT'S
A STRAIGHTJACKET,
BUT IT'S NOT TIED.
>> THAT'S FUN.
>> DO YOU LIKE THAT?
>> I NEED IT TIED.
>> YOU'RE COOL WITH THAT, HUH?
>> WHOO-HOO.
>> I THOUGHT THAT WOULD MAKE YOU
FEEL BETTER TODAY.
>> I FEEL AWESOME.
THANKS!
RENEE GAVE ME, LIKE,
THE COOLEST PICTURE EVER.
AND I THOUGHT
THAT WAS SO AWESOME OF HER,
THAT'S SOME BADASS.
I'M GONNA PUT THIS UP HERE,
SO WHEN I GET READY,
I KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON
IN THE WORLD.
HA!
THAT'S FABULOUS!
♪♪
>> AND I'M GETTING SCARED
BECAUSE WE SEE
THE POLICE OFFICER NEXT TO OUR
LIMO.
>> STEP OUT OF THE CAR, PLEASE.
>> I'M LIKE, OH, GREAT.
WHAT HAVE WE GOTTEN OURSELVES
INTO?
TOP MODELS ALL GETTING ARRESTED.
>> LADIES, I'M NOT ACTUALLY
A TRAFFIC COP.
MY NAME IS BENNY NINJA,
AND I AM GOING TO BE
YOUR POSE COACH FOR TODAY.
>> YEAH!
>> WHOO! (laughs)
>> LET'S HIT IT.
>> WHOO!
>> WELCOME, LADIES.
I AM THE FATHER
OF THE HOUSE OF NINJA,
AND WE HAVE PERFECTED
VOGUING.
>> (cheering)
>> VOGUING STARTED
BACK IN THE '70s IN HARLEM.
WE TOOK IT TO THE CLUBS
AND WE HAD POSING BATTLES.
WHEN YOU ADD MOVEMENT TO POSING,
YOU COME UP WITH VOGUING.
VOGUING.
VOGUING. OKAY?
WHATEVER POSITION YOU'RE IN...
EXAGGERATE IT.
YOU WANT A DIFFERENT SHOT
EACH TIME.
YOU DON'T WANT TO WASTE HIS ROLL
OF FILM.
OKAY, I HAVE A LITTLE FUN
EXERCISE
FOR YOU GIRLS.
I'M GONNA HAVE YOU GIRLS
BATTLE EACH OTHER
ON YOUR POSES.
>> (laughing)
>> OKAY, I'M GONNA TAKE YOU,
AND I WANT YOU.
>> HE POINTS TO ME
AND THEN HE POINTS TO SARAH.
SO I'M LIKE,
OKAY, LET'S DO THIS.
>> YOUR BATTLE IS FACE POSES.
START.
NEXT.
FELICIA IS AN AMAZING GIRL.
SHE IS A NATURAL AT POSING.
POSE.
VERY GOOD.
SHE SERVED.
>> WHOO! YOU GOT SERVED!
(laughter)
>> TURNS OUT...
(chuckles) I KICKED ASS!
>> WHO'S GOING TO SHOW
THE BEST SHOE?
POSE.
YOU DON'T ALWAYS
HAVE TO STAND UP.
IT'S ABOUT THE SHOE.
POSE. OKAY?
HANDBAG.
POSE.
NEXT.
VERY GOOD, LADIES. VERY GOOD.
>> (laughs)
>> THIS IS ELEGANT MODEL ON THE
FLOOR.
POSE.
>> OH, MY GOD,
I WOULD'VE NEVER THOUGHT
THAT I COULD'VE VOGUED.
IT WAS LIKE, YOU KNOW, ROOKIE.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME,
I DID A GOOD JOB.
>> VERY GOOD.
YOU GUYS WERE FABULOUS.
>> YEAH!
>> THIS IS ALL ABOUT YOUR FACES.
POSE.
WHITNEY WAS FABULOUS.
SHE HAS THE ABILITY TO GO
FROM ONE POSE INTO THE NEXT POSE
AND INTO THE NEXT POSE,
WHICH IS BASICALLY WHAT I WAS
TRYING
TO TEACH THE GIRLS TODAY.
SHE GAVE ME EVERYTHING
I WAS LOOKING FOR.
YES! AND POSE.
THAT'S EXACTLY HOW IT GOES.
>> WHOO!
>> THAT IS EXACTLY HOW IT GOES.
>> YEAH! THAT'S MY GIRL!
>> OKAY, GIRLS,
WHAT ARE WE GONNA DO?
>> PRACTICE, PRACTICE, PRACTICE!
>> PRACTICE HOW TO POSE!
>> BENNY NINJA WAS AMAZING.
I FELT LIKE I LEARNED A LOT
FROM--FROM JUST, YOU KNOW,
THAT TIME THAT WE SPENT
WITH HIM.
>> THANK YOU!
>> YOU'RE WELCOME!
>> BYE, BENNY!
>> TYRA MAIL!
"THE BEST WAY
TO COMMIT THIS CRIME
IS TO LOOK GOOD DOING IT...
LOVE, TYRA."
>> YES! (laughs)
>> WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO
VOGUE IT UP.
>> YES?
>> WHAT IS A FIERCE FACE?
>> FIERCE?
THIS IS TOO MUCH.
>> YEAH.
>> THIS IS JUST ENOUGH.
>> FELICIA'S JUST GROWN ON ME
SO MUCH.
I KINDA, YOU KNOW,
LIKE, LOOK AT HER
LIKE A LITTLE SISTER.
SHE'S SUCH A BEAUTIFUL GIRL.
SHE LOOKS LIKE TYRA,
AND I THINK THAT SHE'S,
YOU KNOW, GONNA DO WELL
IN THE COMPETITION.
COME ON, LET'S GO LOOK
AT TYRA'S PICTURES.
>> YEAH.
DOES SHE HAVE A FIERCE ONE?
>> IT JUST WANTS
TO BE DREADLOCKS.
>> THEY'RE GONNA HAVE TO GET YOU
A NEW ONE, DUDE.
>> IT'S SO BAD.
RENEE SORT OF HAS
THIS DOUBLE SIDE TO HER.
SHE CAN BE A LOT OF FUN
AND SHE CAN BE REALLY NICE,
BUT SHE HAS, LIKE,
THIS BITCHY UNDERTONE TO THINGS.
BUT I'M HAPPY AS LONG AS,
YOU KNOW, SHE'S NICE TO ME.
>> WELL, I'VE NEVER HAD A WEAVE,
SO I'M JUST GOING OFF
OF WHAT I SEE IN THE MOVIES.
>> RENEE IS VERY MANIPULATIVE,
AND I BELIEVE SHE LOOKS FOR
A GIRL IN THE HOUSE
TO TRY TO...
YOU KNOW, BE THERE FOR HER
AND TRY TO "CONTROL" HER
IN A SENSE.
SO I DON'T BUY IT.
I DON'T BUY IT.
>> COOL BEANS.
♪♪
>> I HAVE NO HAIR,
SO I DON'T KNOW
WHAT I'M TRYING TO DO. (laughs)
(groans)
MY FRIEND PASSED AWAY,
SO I'M SURE IT'S DUE TO HAVING
REALLY SUPER FRAZZLED NERVES.
♪♪
>> WE ARRIVE
AT THIS HUGE BUILDING
IN DOWNTOWN LOS ANGELES.
AND I'M LIKE, OH, MY GOD.
WHAT ARE WE DOING?
♪♪
>> OOH.
>> (cheering)
>> OOH! (laughs)
>> HOW'S EVERYBODY DOING?
>> GOOD.
>> YOU HAVE ENTERED
THE HOUSE OF LE BANKS,
WHERE TYRA KEEPS
HER MOST BANKABLE POSING SECRETS
LOCKED UP.
(lock tumblers rattle)
>> YESTERDAY YOU LEARNED ABOUT
POSING AND MOVEMENT.
AND TODAY WE ARE GOING
TO PUT YOU TO THE TEST.
ONE OF YOU LADIES
WILL WIN THIS...
A $40,000 DIAMOND BRACELET
FROM angara.com.
>> (laughing)
>> OH, MY GOD!
>> BUT YOU KNOW
I'M GONNA MAKE YOU WORK FOR IT.
>> (laughs)
>> EACH OF YOU
WILL GET THE CHANCE
TO SHOW ME YOUR CATLIKE AGILITY
AND FABULOUS POSES
WHILE SLINKING THROUGH
A CRAZY MAZE OF LASERS.
>> OH, MY GOD!
>> NOW GO GET DRESSED
AND MEET ME BACK IN THE VAULT.
>> (cheering and laughing)
>> LET'S GO. COME ON.
>> THE PRIZE IS
A $40,000 DIAMOND BRACELET.
>> HELL, YEAH, YOU GUYS.
>> I HAVE TO WIN THIS.
IHAVE GOT TO WIN THIS.
MY HUSBAND AND I
ARE REALLY BROKE RIGHT NOW.
THIS WOULD BE A FRESH START
FOR MY FAMILY AND I.
>> WELCOME, LADIES.
THIS... IS YOUR CHALLENGE.
>> OH!
>> (laughs)
>> OH.
>> WHOA!
>> NOW FOR THE RULES.
EACH OF YOU
WILL HAVE TWO MINUTES
TO MAKE IT THROUGH
THE ENTIRE MAZE.
IF YOU TOUCH A LASER,
A BUZZER WILL SOUND...
(buzzer sounds)
>> WHICH WILL PROMPT YOU
TO GO BACK TO THE BEGINNING
AND START OVER.
EACH GIRL WHO MAKES IT
THROUGH THE MAZE
WILL PICK UP A KEY
WHICH MAY OPEN THE BOX
WITH THE DIAMOND PRIZE INSIDE.
>> OH, MY GOD!
>> EVEN THOUGH
YOU'VE MADE IT THROUGH,
IT DOES NOT MEAN YOU'VE WON.
I WILL DECIDE
WHO HAD THE MOST POISE AND GRACE
WHILE POSING THROUGH THE MAZE,
AND THAT PERSON
WILL BE THE WINNER.
DIONNE, YOU ARE FIRST.
>> OH, NO! (laughs)
>> GOOD LUCK.
>> I'M LIKE, WHAT THE HELL?!
ME?
YOU WANNA PICK ME FIRST?
I SEE ALL THESE LASERS
GOING ALL KIND OF CRAZY WAYS,
AND I'M LIKE, HOW THE HELL
I'M-A GET THROUGH HERE
AND POSE AT THE SAME TIME?
>> BEGIN.
(sounds buzzer)
>> GO BACK.
>> I'M MAKING MY WAY
THROUGH THIS MAZE AND BOOM--
MY HAIR TOUCHES A LINE
OR SOMETHING,
AND I HAVE TO GO BACK.
(sensor buzzes)
(sounds buzzer)
>> GO BACK TO THE BEGINNING.
>> BOOM! I TOUCH ANOTHER ONE.
(sensor buzzes)
(sounds buzzer)
(sensor buzzing)
>> I'M LIKE, I CAN'T POSE
AND GET THROUGH HERE
ALL AT ONE TIME.
>> 20 SECONDS.
>> SO I'M JUST GONNA DIVE
AND GO THROUGH HERE
AND TAKE THE EASIEST WAY--
ROLL OR SOMETHING.
JUST MAKE SURE
YOU GET THROUGH IT
SO YOU CAN GET A KEY.
>> FIVE, FOUR,
THREE, TWO,
ONE.
>> (laughs)
>> CONGRATULATIONS.
GRAB A KEY.
>> THAT WAS HARDER
THAN I THOUGHT.
>> NEXT UP IS BRITTANY.
AND... GO.
>> REMEMBER TO POSE.
RIGHT.
CONGRATULATIONS.
GRAB A KEY.
GO.
>> WHEN I GO
INTO THE LASER MAZE CHALLENGE,
WHAT I'M THINKING ABOUT
IS POSE YOUR TAIL OFF
AND DO THE BEST JOB
THAT YOU POSSIBLY CAN.
>> POSE.
CORRECT.
WHITNEY BLEW MY MIND.
HER POSES WERE PHENOMENAL.
AND SHE KEPT EYE CONTACT
WITH ME THE WHOLE ENTIRE TIME.
CONGRATULATIONS.
GRAB YOUR KEY.
BEGIN.
REMEMBER TO POSE.
CORRECT.
I WAS JUST TRYING
TO DO MY THING--POSE,
TRY TO BE AS SEXY AS I CAN...
>> CORRECT.
>> AND MY WHOLE THING WAS JUST
TO GET TO THE FINISH LINE.
>> CONGRATULATIONS.
GRAB A KEY.
THERE YOU GO.
SHE IS A DANCER.
THE MAZE IS VERY EASY FOR ME
BECAUSE I GOT TO USE
MY DANCE BACKGROUND
TO MY ADVANTAGE.
>> CONGRATULATIONS.
PICK A KEY.
FIVE... FOUR...
THREE... TWO...
ONE.
(stopwatch beeps)
>> CONGRATULATIONS.
GRAB A KEY.
MM-HMM.
CONGRATULATIONS.
GRAB A KEY.
FIVE... FOUR...
THREE... TWO...
ONE.
CONGRATULATIONS.
GRAB A KEY.
>> WHOO, LORD!
I THINK I ACTED A DAMN FOOL,
BUT I HAD SUCH A GOOD TIME.
>> GREAT USE OF BODY MOVEMENT.
(sensor buzzes)
(sounds buzzer)
>> THAT'S NOT HOW
YOU'RE GONNA GET THAT BRACELET.
(sensor buzzing)
>> YEAH, YOU WANT THAT PRIZE,
DON'T YOU?
I WOULD, TOO.
(sensor buzzes)
(sounds buzzer)
>> BUT YOU WON'T GET IT THAT
WAY.
(sensor buzzing)
>> TEN... NINE... EIGHT...
SEVEN... SIX... FIVE...
(sensor buzzes)
(sounds buzzer)
>> SO SORRY.
>> I JUST CAN'T BELIEVE
THAT EVERY GIRL
THAT WENT BEFORE ME GOT A KEY,
AND I DIDN'T GET A KEY.
I WAS HOPING
THAT I COULD USE THIS
TO PAY OFF ALL OF THE BILLS
THAT--YOU KNOW,
WE'RE SWIMMING IN DEBT.
WE DON'T HAVE ANY PLACE TO LIVE.
AND I JUST FEEL LIKE I FAILED.
I FEEL LIKE I FAILED MY FAMILY.
>> LADIES,
YOU GUYS WERE TERRIFIC.
RENEE,
YOU DIDN'T MAKE IT THROUGH,
BUT YOU TRIED YOUR HARDEST.
NOW REMEMBER, GIRLS,
I HAVE CHOSEN THE WINNER
BASED ON THE GIRL I FELT
HAD THE BEST POSING AND MOVEMENT
THROUGHOUT THE MAZE,
AND HER KEY WILL OPEN THE BOX
WITH THE DIAMOND PRIZE INSIDE.
LADIES, OPEN YOUR BOX.
>> (gasps)
>> WHOO!
>> YEAH!
>> (cheering)
>> OH, MY.
>> OH, MY GOD!
OH!
I WON THE CHALLENGE.
(laughs)
>> OH, WHITNEY!
>> I OWE MY FATHER $9,000...
(laughs) FOR MY EDUCATION.
BUT, UM, I THINK THAT WHAT
I'M PROBABLY GONNA DO
IS KEEP THE BRACELET
BECAUSE THERE'S A LOT
OF SENTIMENTAL VALUE TO IT.
>> (laughs)
>> TYRA MAIL!
>> "DON'T KILL YOURSELF
WITH OVERTHINKING
THE COMPETITION,
BUT KILL ME WITH
YOUR DROP-DEAD GORGEOUS LOOKS.
LOVE, TYRA."
>> OOH!
>> (laughs)
>> I REALLY FEEL LIKE
MY SPIRIT'S BEEN BROKEN
SINCE I'VE BEEN HERE.
LIKE, I CAME IN HERE--
"OH, I'M GONNA
ROCK THIS COMPETITION,"
AND I HAVEN'T BEEN.
>> I WAS LIKE THIS...
(laughter)
(phone ringing)
>> Hello?
>> HI, BABY.
>> Hi, babe.
>> DO YOU WANT TO COME PICK ME
UP?
>> What's wrong?
>> I DON'T WANT TO BE HERE
ANYMORE.
>> So what's going on? What's
wrong?
>> I JUST DON'T WANT TO BE HERE.
IT'S JUST STUPID THAT I'M HERE.
I SHOULD BE WITH MY FAMILY.
I SHOULDN'T BE HERE
WITH ALL THESE STUPID GIRLS.
>> IS SHE ON THE PHONE?
IT IS MY TURN.
>> I WANTED TO GO, LIKE,
FOUR, FIVE MINUTES--
>> WILL SHE GET MAD?
>> I MISS YOU GUYS SO MUCH.
>> I miss you, too.
We all miss you, too, babe.
>> (crying)
>> SHE BETTER GET OFF
THAT DAMN PHONE.
>> SHE WAS THE FIRST PERSON
IN THERE.
>> Did you have a good day
today?
>> NO.
>> No?
>> I HAD TO GET OFF
'CAUSE SHE ALREADY WENT.
>> NATASHA, GO WITH FIFI.
TELL HER IT'S MY TURN.
>> (laughs)
OH, SHE MISSES HER BABY.
>> YEAH, I KNOW.
YOU OKAY, GIRL?
>> I DON'T WANT TO--GO AWAY.
I'M TALKING TO MY HUSBAND.
>> IT'S OKAY.
(slams door)
>> (crying)
I CANNOT STAND THESE GIRLS,
JASON.
I SWEAR TO GOD, I'M GONNA...
BEAT THEM ALL... DOWN.
>> SHE ALMOST GOT SLAPPED.
>> WHAT'D YOU DO TO HER?
>> I DIDN'T DO NOTHING TO HER.
>> YOU DIDN'T GET ALL--
>> I JUST WENT IN THERE
AND ASKED HER IF SHE WAS OKAY,
AND SHE SAID, "GO AWAY.
I'M TALKING TO MY HUSBAND."
I WAS LIKE, OKAY, WELL, YEAH,
I NEED TO GET ON THE PHONE, TOO,
AND, UM,
YOU'VE BEEN ON THERE ALREADY.
>> AND WHAT'D SHE SAY?
>> SHE AIN'T HAD A CHANCE
TO SAY, "...CLOSE THE DOOR."
RENEE KNOWS THAT SHE'S BEEN
LASHING OUT ON THE GIRLS.
SHE'S--YOU KNOW, HER ATTITUDE'S
BEEN FLARING A LITTLE BIT,
AND WE GET BACK TO THE HOUSE,
AND IT--THERE'S NOTHING CHANGED.
RENEE CAN SWITCH ON YOU.
SO IT'S, LIKE, YOU NEVER KNOW
WHICH ONE YOU'RE GONNA GET
ON WHAT DAYS WITH HER,
SO YOU HAVE TO BE CAREFUL.
>> WHOO!
>> BITCH!
♪♪
>> WE ARRIVE AT THE ALEXANDRIA
HOTEL,
AND WE GO UPSTAIRS TO THE 12th
FLOOR.
>> WELL, GOOD MORNING.
HOW ARE YOU GUYS?
>> GOOD.
>> WHAT HAVE YOU GUYS BEEN
LEARNING ABOUT ALL WEEK?
>> POSING.
>> WELL, YOU KNOW,SOMETIMES YOU
NEED TO LEARN
HOW TO BRING A LITTLE LIFE TO A
DEAD POSE.
SO THE SHOOT IS, YOU GIRLS ARE
ALL GONNA BE
CRIME SCENE VICTIMS.
>> WOW.
(laughs)
>> YOU'RE ALL GONNA BE DEAD IN
YOUR PHOTO.
>> AAH!
>> AND THE TWIST IS
YOU'VE ALL KILLED EACH OTHER.
I DON'T WANT YOU GUYS TO JUST
BE LYING THERE LIKE THIS...
(grunts)
(laughter)
>> I WANNA SEE SOME LIFE
EVEN THOUGH YOU'RE DEAD.
>> HE'S SAYING
YOU HAVE TO BE DEAD
YET ALIVE IN THE FACE.
IT'S SORT OF LIKE AN OXYMORON,
AND I'M THINKING,
WELL, HOW ARE YOU SUPPOSED
TO DO THAT AND BE DEAD?
>> AND TODAY WE'VE GOT SOMEBODY
WHO KNOWS ALL ABOUT SHOOTING
HIGH-FASHION EDITORIAL.
HE'S WORKED WITH US
MANY, MANY TIMES--
MR. MIKE ROSENTHAL.
>> WHOO!
>> HOW YOU DOING, JAY?
>> OKAY, SO LET'S MAKE OUR WAY
DOWN TO HAIR AND MAKEUP,
AND LET'S HAVE FUN.
>> OKAY.
♪♪
>> I CAN'T BELIEVE
WITH THAT LITTLE HAIR
YOU MANAGED TO BURN YOUR SKIN.
>> I'VE BEEN FRAZZLED THIS WEEK,
BUT I'M GONNA
BRING A GOOD PICTURE.
>> SHE SHOULD BE THE BURN VICTIM
TODAY.
>> (laughs)
>> OKAY.
>> I'M REALLY NERVOUS
TO GO UP THERE
BECAUSE I WAS THE ONLY ONE
AT THAT CHALLENGE YESTERDAY
WHO DIDN'T MAKE IT
ALL THE WAY THROUGH.
SO I REALLY NEED
TO DO A REALLY GOOD JOB.
>> LOOK AT THAT.
HOW EERIE IS THAT?
>> GREAT.
(camera shutter snapping)
>> I HAVE SO LITTLE TO SAY.
THIS IS REALLY GOOD.
RENEE, THIS IS SO EDITORIAL
AND HIGH FASHION.
>> THANK YOU.
>> LIKE, I WOULD EXPECT THIS,
LIKE, OUT OF A REAL SUPERMODEL.
>> I DID AWESOME! (laughs)
BUT I'M NOT GONNA TELL THE GIRLS
HOW GOOD I DID OR WHAT JAY SAID,
BECAUSE THEY ALREADY
HATE ME ENOUGH AS IT IS.
>> RENEE WAS SO GOOD.
CHA-CHA, SHE'S COMING FOR YOU.
>> INTIMIDATION'S MY MOTIVATION.
>> NO, I'M BEING HONEST.
EVERY FRAME,
INCLUDING HER TEST SHOTS,
IS PERFECT FOR JUDGING.
>> OH, THEY DO?
>> YEAH.
>> I KNOW YOU'RE CREATIVE,
SO WHY DON'T YOU FIND
A PRETTY WAY TO FALL?
>> NICE.
>> I LOVE IT
'CAUSE HER ANKLE LOOKS BROKEN.
>> MY BIGGEST COMPETITION,
I WOULD HAVE TO SAY, IS JASLENE.
SHE IS VERY, VERY GOOD
AT MODELING.
SHE'S VERY, VERY GOOD AT IT.
>> EXCELLENT.
>> CLOSER.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT?
I REALLY DON'T MIND
THAT THE GIRLS ARE WATCHING.
THEY DON'T FAZE ME WHATSOEVER.
YOU KNOW, I KNOW WHAT
I'M CAPABLE OF.
SO REGARDLESS OF WHO'S AROUND,
I'M STILL GONNA DO ME
AND CHA-CHA DIVA SURE IS OUT.
>> ALL RIGHT, CHA-CHA.
WHAT WE SHOT SO FAR
IS REALLY BEAUTIFUL.
>> THIS IS SO GROSS, YOU GUYS.
>> IT'S SO GROSS.
>> WHAT IF I SORT OF--
LIKE I FELL OUT?
>> YEAH, TRY IT.
LET'S SEE WHAT YOU CAN DO.
>> THAT'S GREAT. THAT'S GREAT.
PERFECT.
>> I HATE TO DO THIS TO YOU,
REALLY.
>> NO, YOU DON'T!
YOU'RE ENJOYING IT.
>> EW!
>> I WAS ON THE BATHROOM FLOOR
COVERED WITH WATER.
EVERYTHING THAT WAS ON THERE
IS ALL OVER ME NOW,
SO THAT'S PRETTY GROSS.
>> GOOD JOB, BRITT.
YOU ALWAYS COMMIT.
>> (laughs nervously)
(whines) CAN I HAVE A TOWEL?
>> SOMEONE GET THIS GIRL
A TOWEL AND A TETANUS SHOT.
UGH!
>> ONCE EVERYBODY
STARTED TO GET THEIR MAKEUP ON
AND EVERYTHING,
I WAS SO INTO LOOKING
AT EVERYBODY.
FELICIA SCARED THE HELL
OUT OF ME THOUGH, WITH HER--
THAT NECK THING?!
IT LOOKED SO FREAKIN' DISEASED.
AND DIANA...
DON'T TALK ABOUT DIANA.
EW!
>> MY CRIME SCENE IS
WHITNEY STOLE ALL OF MY ORGANS
AND THEN STITCHED ME BACK UP.
HA! (laughs)
>> CAN YOU MAKE THAT RIGHT HAND
LOOK AT LITTLE MORE
KINDA BROKEN?
THERE YOU GO.
(camera shutter snapping)
>> THAT LOOKS GORGEOUS.
GOOD SHOT, DIANA.
>> THIS IS THE BEST MAKEUP EVER.
I'VE BEEN WALKING AROUND
SO EXCITED ALL DAY.
>> LORD, LORD, LORD. OKAY.
OOH! NO, YOU'RE ALL BLOODY.
UGH.
I DON'T WANT YOU
TO OVERTHINK THIS.
>> OKAY, I KNOW.
>> MIKE, SHE'S A PHOTOGRAPHER.
>> ALL RIGHT.
>> 'CAUSE SHE'S GONNA
THINK THE POSE FOR YOU.
>> BECAUSE I AM A PHOTOGRAPHER,
I ALMOST THINK ABOUT IT
TOO MUCH,
AND HE--HE'S TRYING
TO BEAT THAT OUT OF ME.
(camera shutter snaps)
>> DO SOMETHING ELSE
WITH YOUR RIGHT HAND.
YEAH. THERE, THAT'S GOOD.
DON'T WRINKLE YOUR FOREHEAD
'CAUSE YOU'RE DEAD.
(camera shutter snaps)
>> IT'S FEELING REALLY COZY
RIGHT NOW.
>> IT'S JUST LOOKING LIKE
YOU'RE TRYING TO LOOK DEAD,
BUT IT'S NOT WORKING.
(camera shutter snaps)
>> LAST FRAME.
THAT'S IT.
OKAY.
WHAT ARE YOU THINKING ABOUT,
JAEL?
>> MY FRIEND WHO OVERDOSED
A WEEK AGO.
>> REALLY?
>> YEAH.
>> I'M NOT SURE IF THAT
WAS THE RIGHT WAY TO GO.
I'LL TELL YOU WHY.
YOU GOT INTO A PLACE
THAT IS REALLY, REALLY HEAVY,
AND IT ALLOWED YOU NOT TO FOCUS
ON WHAT YOU WERE DOING.
AND IT'S IMPORTANT TO USE
THAT EMOTION WITHOUT IT...
>> OVERWHELMING?
>> OVERWHELMING YOU,
AND IT PROBABLY OVERWHELMED YOU.
>> YEAH. I REALIZE THAT NOW.
>> YOU KNOW?
>> AND I REALLY HOPE
I GOT A GOOD SHOT BECAUSE I...
>> THERE ARE GOOD SHOTS.
BUT YOU JUST CAN'T LET IT
OVERWHELM YOU.
YOU NEED TO STILL BE ABLE
TO FUNCTION IN IT.
OKAY?
>> OKAY.
>> UNFORTUNATELY,
I DIDN'T KNOW WHAT WAS GOING ON
IN JAEL'S LIFE.
IN THE END,
I THINK HER SHOT WAS OKAY,
BUT IT WAS CLEAR THAT SHE HAD--
SHE WAS NOT FOCUSING
ON THE SHOOT AT ALL.
ALL RIGHT, LET'S GO--
LET'S GO BACK IN THE OTHER ROOM.
>> WELL, I CAN'T BE FUN
ALL THE TIME, JAY.
>> NO, I KNOW.
NO, I KNOW, I KNOW, I KNOW,
I KNOW.
>> I DON'T THINK
ANYONE REALIZES, LIKE,
HOW TRAUMATIC THIS IS RIGHT NOW.
I DON'T EVEN REMEMBER
BEING IN THAT ROOM
GETTING MY PICTURE TAKEN.
ALL I REMEMBER
IS TRYING TO HOLD, LIKE,
MY TEARS.
>> CAMERA SHAKE.
>> (chuckles) OKAY.
>> (gravelly voice) I'M GONNA
GET YOU AFTER THIS.
>> YOU'RE NOT LOOKING
IN THE CAMERA.
YOU JUST--WE WANT
A GLAZED OVER PICTURE
LIKE A DEAD BODY.
>> YOU LOOK LIKE A CORPSE.
>> THANK YOU, JAY.
(normal voice) I'M THINKING
ABOUT NOTHING WHEN I'M POSING.
IT'S JUST A BLANK STARE
JUST, LIKE, INTO THE CLOUDS.
LIKE, JUST...
BASICALLY, YOU'RE DEAD.
(chuckles)
>> THAT LOOKS LIKE
YOU'RE TAKING A NAP.
WE NEED IT TO LOOK LIKE
YOU WERE BRUTALLY KILLED.
>> YEAH.
>> TYRA TOLD ME LAST ELIMINATION
THAT SOME OF THE JUDGES
DIDN'T THINK THAT I WAS A MODEL
AND THAT I WAS, YOU KNOW,
JUST A PRETTY FACE
AND THAT THEY WANTED TO KNOW
IF I COULD BRING IT
AND POSE LIKE A MODEL POSES.
WELL, DEFINITELY
FUEL FOR THE FIRE
AND I TRIED TO BRING IT
AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE TODAY.
>> GOOD.
>> AAH!
>> I'M SORRY! (laughs)
>> OH! (crying)
>> NATASHA,
THIS IS NOT AS COLD AS RUSSIA.
>> OH, MY GOSH.
THEY'RE POURING THE WATER ON ME.
IT FEELING LIKE NEEDLES
GOING THROUGH MY BODY
FROM MY SKIN.
>> YEAH, KEEP YOUR HEAD
TURNED THIS WAY FOR A SECOND.
LIKE, YOUR HEAD THAT WAY.
>> YEAH.
>> GORGEOUS.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT HAPPENED
WITH SOME OF YOU GIRLS.
YOU WENT FROM NONMODEL TO MODEL
IN TWO SHOOTS.
>> THANK YOU, MR. JAY.
>> BRING YOUR FACE THIS WAY.
>> I LOOKED LIKE
A DEAD-ASS RICH WOMAN, FOR REAL.
MY DRESS WAS BLACK
AND SO SCANDALOUS.
>> THAT'S FEELING MODEL-Y.
BUT WHEREVER YOU'RE LOOKING,
KEEP IT SO IT'S NOT FOCUSED.
BEND ONE OF YOUR LEGS,
LET YOUR ARM FLAP OVER THE POLE.
DIONNE TOOK A LITTLE WHILE
TO WARM UP,
AND SHE REALLY DIDN'T
TAKE MUCH INITIATIVE
TO IMPROVISE.
MUCH MORE BELIEVABLE.
>> IT'S KIND OF SCARY.
EVERYBODY'S KIND OF GOOD TODAY.
I DON'T KNOW
WHAT THAT MEANS EXACTLY.
>> THAT MEANS
NOBODY'S GOING HOME.
>> I THINK THE JUDGES
ARE GONNA HAVE
A REALLY TOUGH TIME,
BECAUSE EVERY GIRL HAS DELIVERED
IN A WAY THAT I NEVER EXPECTED.
♪♪
>> TYRA MAIL!
>> "TOMORROW
YOU WILL MEET WITH THE JUDGES.
ONLY NINE WILL CONTINUE ON
THE HOPES OF BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
LOVE, TYRA."
>> ♪& BOM-BOM-BOM ♪&
>> I'LL BE SO RELIEVED
IF I JUST GET A GOOD REVIEW.
>> I DON'T KNOW.
>> IF I GET A GOOD REVIEW,
I'M-A BE LIKE...
(singsong voice)
I AIN'T GOING HOME!
>> YOU'RE A BIG KID.
>> (normal voice) I KNOW. RIGHT?
I THINK MY PHOTO SHOOT
KICKED ASS.
I AM ALMOST POSITIVE
THAT I GOT A GOOD SHOT
FOR PANEL.
>> I REALLY WISH I'D HAVE GOTTEN
THE OPPORTUNITY TO DO MY THING.
I WOULD'VE DONE SO GOOD.
>> ARE YOU WORRIED?
>> HELL, YEAH, I'M WORRIED.
I DIDN'T DO MY BEST.
I WAS TRAUMATIZED.
THAT'S NOT COOL, YOU KNOW?
I DON'T THINK
I TOOK THAT GOOD ENOUGH PHOTO.
I THINK I MIGHT BE GOING HOME.
IT'S VERY UPSETTING TO ME.
♪♪
>> WELL, HELLO, EVERYONE.
SO YOU KNOW OUR PRIZES.
THE WINNER WILL RECEIVE A
CONTRACT,
WITH ELITE MODEL MANAGEMENT,
WHICH IS ONE OF THE TOP MODELING
AGENCIES
IN THE ENTIRE WORLD...
A SPREAD AND A COVER OF
"SEVENTEEN" MAGAZINE...
AND ALSO YOU'RE GOING TO GET
A $100,000 CONTRACT WITH
COVERGIRL COSMETICS.
YOU KNOW OUR JUDGES.
THE FIRST IS NIGEL BARKER,
NOTED FASHION PHOTOGRAPHER.
>> HI, LADIES.
>> HI.
>> MISS J. ALEXANDER,
RUNWAY DIVA COACH
EXTRAORDINAIRE.
DO YOU NOTICE?
HE HAS FOUR RUFFLES
REPRESENTING THE FOUR GIRLS
THAT ARE RESTING IN PEACE
RIGHT NOW...
>> (laughs)
>> THAT ARE NOT WITH US HERE,
THAT HAVE BEEN ELIMINATED.
TWIGGY, OUR FASHION DIVA.
>> HELLO, LADIES.
>> HEY.
>> AND MIKE ROSENTHAL.
HE HAS TO BE ONE OF
MY MOST FAVORITE PHOTOGRAPHERS
THAT GUESTS
ON "AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL."
ALL RIGHT, GIRLS, SO THIS WEEK
YOU LEARNED ALL ABOUT POSING.
AND FOR YOUR PHOTO SHOOT,
YOU HAD TO BREATHE LIFE
INTO DEAD POSES
AS YOU TRIED TO ELIMINATE
YOUR COMPETITION.
SO NOW IT'S TIME
FOR YOUR INDIVIDUAL EVALUATIONS,
AND RENEE IS FIRST.
YOU HAD A PHOTO SHOOT
WHERE YOU WERE TERRORIZED
BY THE MODELS IN THE HOUSE.
AND WHAT DID THEY DO TO YOU?
>> YOU KNOW HOW
EVERYBODY ALWAYS SAYS
THAT FELICIA LOOKS LIKE YOU?
>> UH-HUH.
>> I REALLY DON'T THINK
SHE LOOKS A THING LIKE YOU,
SO I TOLD HER THAT,
AND SHE POISONED ME.
>> ALL RIGHT,
LET'S SEE YOUR BEST
"FELICIA POISONED YOU" SHOT.
>> YOU'VE GOT A BEAUTIFUL
HEART-SHAPED JAW,
WHICH SHOWS WONDERFULLY.
>> AND THE THING
THAT'S GREAT ABOUT THIS IS THAT
YOU CAN ALSO LOOK BEAUTIFUL
IN DEATH.
>> THANK YOU.
>> YEAH, BUT YOU
KNOW WHAT, RENEE?
YOU LOOK INCREDIBLE IN FRONT OF
ME HERE
YOU LOOK BEAUTIFUL IN THIS
PICTURE.
THIS IS A FULL PACKAGE RIGHT
NOW.
>> ALL RIGHT, THANKS, RENEE.
ALL RIGHT, UP NEXT IS DIONNE.
YOU STILL LOOK LIKE
YOU'RE AUDITIONING
FOR "TOP MODEL," NOT LIKE--
NOT LIKE THIS IS THE FIFTH WEEK.
>> I DO?!
>> NO.
>> OH, THAT'S NOT GOOD.
>> THAT TANK TOP IS NOT GOOD.
>> TOO MUCH.
>> THE LACE, THE TWINKLES, THE
COLOR.
>> YEAH.
>> IT LOOKS KIND OF LIKE A MALL
LOOK.
>> I FEEL LIKE YOUR BANG IS A
LITTLE TOO PERFECT, TOO.
ALL RIGHT, WHAT HAPPENED TO YOU?
>> SARAH WAS SO JEALOUS OF MY
MIND-BLOWING LOOKS,SHE BLEW MY
MIND.
>> OOH, GIRL! ALL RIGHT!
>> WHOO!
>> ABSOLUTELY BEAUTIFUL.
>> I LOVE THE BROKEN-DOWN LEG.
>> ME, TOO.
>> IT'S ABSOLUTELY GENIUS.
>> JAY SAID THAT YOU DID WELL
WITH DIFFERENT SHOTS
AND YOU GAVE VARIATIONS,
BUT HE HAD TO POSITION YOU.
>> I'M NOT GONNA LIE. HE DID.
>> THE REASON W\HY THIS SHOT
WORKS SO AMAZINGLY WELL
IS THE POSITIONING OF YOUR BODY.
>> MM-HMM.
>> ON TOP OF THAT,
THE ACTUAL BACKGROUND,
THE WAY IT'S LIT--
THIS IS ONE OF THOSE SHOTS
WHERE IF I TOOK THAT
ALL AWAY FROM YOU,
THEN HOW GREAT WOULD YOU LOOK?
>> NATASHA.
>> THAT'S A POWERFUL
A PHOTOGRAPH.
MY GOODNESS.
>> LAST WEEK AND THIS WEEK,
DO YOU KNOW WHAT'S
THE SIMILAR THING
WITH THE PHOTOS?
>> THE EYES?
>> NO, UPSIDE DOWN.
WHEN YOU'RE UPRIGHT, YOU GO...
AND YOU DO THIS.
BUT THE MINUTE YOU GO UPSIDE
DOWN,
IT, LIKE, PULLS IT AND IT GOES
BACKWARDS.
SO YOU HAVE TO FIGURE OUT--
HOW CAN I GET THIS... LIKE THAT?
>> YEAH.
>> IT WAS FREEZING,
AND SHE STILL DID
A FANTASTIC JOB.
>> THIS IS THE REASON WHY YOU'RE
HERE FOR WEEK FIVE.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> THANKS, NATASHA.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> ALL RIGHT, UP NEXT IS DIANA.
ALL RIGHT, DIANA,
HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
>> MY, GOODNESS ME.
>> THESE ARE BROKEN-DOWN DOLLS.
THESE ARE BUSTED UP,
OLD BROKEN-DOWN DOLLS--
MARIONETTES.
>> AND THIS IS A GOOD PICTURE.
YOU KNOW, YOU EXECUTED THE IDEA
VERY WELL.
>> YOU DID A FANTASTIC JOB.
AND ESPECIALLY WORKING IN
SUCH A SMALL SPACE,
REALLY AWKWARD HALLWAY.
YOU DID A GREAT JOB.
>> I THINK IT'S A REALLY GOOD
SHOT.
>> I DO, TOO.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>> I DO THINK IT'S A GOOD SHOT.
ALL RIGHT, NEXT IS JAEL.
THIS PHOTO SHOOT THIS WEEK
WAS PROBABLY NOT EASY FOR YOU
BECAUSE IT WAS ABOUT
CRIME SCENES AND DEATH,
AND I KNOW THAT
YOU EXPERIENCED THAT LAST WEEK
WITH YOUR FRIEND,
BUT WE'RE GONNA SEE
YOUR BEST SHOT, OKAY?
>> OF COURSE.
>> WHO WERE YOU?
>> WELL, WHITNEY'S ALWAYS
TAKING THOSE PICTURES WITH NO
NECK,
SO SHE TRIED TO STEAL MINE.
>> ALL RIGHT,SO SHE STRANGLED
YOU.
>> YEAH, LET'S SEE HOW SHE PULLS
IT OFF.
>> ALL RIGHT.
>> REMARKABLE SHOT.
IT'S REALLY--EVERYBODY HAS DONE
EXTREMELY WELL SO FAR.
THIS IS A GOOD SHOT OF YOU, TOO.
IT DOES SHOW US THAT YOU'RE ABLE
TO--IN SUCH ADVERSITY--MANAGE
TO DO A PHOTO SHOOT LIKE THIS.
>> UNDER PRESSURE.
>> YEAH, I THINK IN THE END,
YOU ENDED UP WITH A GREAT SHOT.
>> MM-HMM.
>> UP NEXT IS JASLENE.
SO YOU HAD A PHOTO SHOOT.
WHAT HAPPENED?
>> I HAD SUCH A FIERCE DRESS ON
THAT RENEE JUST PUSHED ME
OFF THE BUILDING.
>> ALL RIGHT.
>> (laughs)
>> IT'S A GREAT SHOT.
IT'S A GREAT SHOT.
DEATH BECOMES YOU, YOUNG LADY.
>> THANK YOU.
>> I LOVE THAT SHE HAS
EYE CONTACT WITH NO EYES.
DOES THAT MAKE SENSE?
>> YEAH.
>> YOU TOOK DIRECTION WELL
AND YOU REALLY WEREN'T SHY.
>> THIS IS ANOTHER GREAT SHOT.
>> ALL RIGHT, UP NEXT IS SARAH.
ALL RIGHT, SARAH,
LET'S SEE YOUR BEST SHOT.
>> IT'S A GREAT PICTURE,
>> THE LOOK IN YOUR FACE
IS JUST EXTRAORDINARY.
I MEAN, VERY BEAUTIFUL
AND DEAD.
>> THAT'S GREAT. YEAH.
>> THANK YOU.
>> I DID FEEL LIKE YOU PUT
A LITTLE TOO MUCH THOUGHT
INTO THE POSE.
BUT I THOUGHT
WITH THE FACIAL EXPRESSIONS,
YOU DID A GREAT JOB.
>> ALL RIGHT, UP NEXT IS
BRITTANY.
LET'S SEE YOUR BEST SHOT.
>> WOW.
>> I LOVE THE LEG.
>> I SUGGESTED
GETTING OUT OF THE TUB BECAUSE
IT SAID I WAS IN THE TUB
AND I WAS LIKE,
WELL, THAT ONLY GIVES ME
A LITTLE BIT OF MY BODY
TO WORK WITH.
>> THIS WAS AMAZING.
SO IF YOU DIDN'T SPEAK UP,
YOU WOULD'VE HAD
A BEAUTIFUL SHOT, YOU KNOW.
BUT YOU SPOKE UP,
AND NOW IT'S PROBABLY
ONE OF THE BEST IN THE BUNCH.
ALL RIGHT,
UP NEXT IS FELICIA.
>> HEY.
>> LET'S SEE YOUR BEST SHOT.
>> ALL THE OTHER GIRLS
HAVE MANAGED TO HAVE
SOME SORT OF SPARKLE EVEN IN
THIS SORT OF MORBID SITUATION.
AND I THINK IN THIS PICTURE,
I LOOK AT YOU,
AND YOU ACTUALLY JUST LOOK DEAD.
>> YOU'RE SO USED TO MOVING,
THAT WHEN YOU HAVE TO BE DEAD
YOU ARE JUST THAT.
CAPITAL D-E-A-D. DEAD.
>> SOME OF THE SIMPLEST THINGS,
LIKE ACTING DEAD,
CAN BE THE MOST CHALLENGING.
THE PROBLEM IS
THAT YOU DIDN'T DO ANYTHING.
YOU JUST GAVE UP
AND THOUGHT THAT WAS BEING DEAD.
>> YOU WERE THE GIRL
THAT STARTED IN THE BEGINNING
WITH SO MUCH VARIATION.
WHY DO YOU THINK
YOU WERE SO STUCK?
>> UGH, I DON'T KNOW.
I THOUGHT IT WAS
GOING TO BE BETTER THAN THAT.
>> OKAY, FELICIA. THANK YOU.
>> (mouths word)
>> LAST BUT NOT LEAST
IS WHITNEY.
>> HELLO.
>> HI, WHITNEY.
I SEE YOU TRYING TO BRAG ABOUT
THAT LITTLE BLING.
(laughter)
>> SHE'S TRYING TO BE
SO SUBTLE ABOUT IT.
A LITTLE BLING. AH, YOU KNOW.
SO TELL US WHY
YOU HAVE YOUR BLING ON.
>> I WON THE CHALLENGE.
>> THE CHALLENGE WAS POSING
THROUGH LASERS,
AND YOU DID A REALLY GOOD JOB,
I HEAR.
AND WHAT HAPPENED TO YOU?
>> WELL, THE GIRLS
ARE SO JEALOUS OF MY UPPER AREA
THAT THEY CHOPPED ME UP
TO SEE IF THEY WERE REAL.
>> (laughing)
>> WELL, LET'S SEE
IF THEY ARE REAL.
>> I THINK YOU LOOK ABSOLUTELY
WONDERFUL,
THE EXTENSION OF THE NECK.
>> YEAH, IT'S GOOD.
IT'S THE FIRST PHOTOGRAPH
I'VE SEEN OF YOU WHERE YOU
ACTUALLY LOOK LIKE
A FASHION MODEL.
>> THAT'S WHAT I WAS GOING FOR.
>> IT'S BEAUTIFUL.
>> AND I AGREE WITH TWIGGY.
THIS IS A FASHION SHOT.
BUT YOU DON'T LOOK DEAD TO ME.
>> IT'S LIKE YOU'RE DYING.
>> YOU LOOK LIKE YOU'RE DYING.
>> YOU LOOK LIKE... WHOO!
>> YEAH, IT'S--
>> EXACTLY.
>> THANK YOU.
>> YOU'RE WELCOME.
ALL RIGHT, SO WE HAVE EXAMINED
ALL OF YOUR PHOTOS,
AND NOW IT'S TIME
FOR US TO DELIBERATE
AND DETERMINE WHICH ONE OF YOU
WILL BE GOING HOME.
>> ALL RIGHT,
SO NOW IT'S TIME TO DECIDE
WHO IS GETTING
THE "TOP MODEL" AX--
NO PUN INTENDED--
FOR THE PHOTO SHOOT
THAT WAS THIS WEEK.
NATASHA.
>> SHE'S TOTALLY UPPED HER GAME.
THIS IS A GREAT SHOT
FOR NATASHA.
>> NATASHA ACTUALLY HAS
A LARGE HEAD.
THE BIGNESS OF HER HEAD
GIVES MORE FOR THE CAMERA
TO GO... (makes whooshing sound)
>> I THINK THIS IS EXCELLENT.
>> I THINK THIS PROVES
THAT THERE IS LIFE AFTER DEATH
AFTER ALL.
>> DIONNE.
>> I WAS RATHER DISTRESSED
BY WHAT DIONNE WAS WEARING
TODAY. (chuckles)
AND SHE DOES NOT
JUMP OUT OF THE LINE TO ME.
>> DIONNE REALLY LACKS
A SORT OF PRESENCE.
AND THE WAY SHE DRESSES HERSELF.
>> SHE'S GOT NO--
SHE'S GOT NO OOMPH.
>> I KNOW IT'S WEEK FIVE,
BUT I STILL FEEL LIKE
THERE'S SOMETHING IN THERE.
IF YOU GIVE HER A STILETTO,
GAVE HER A LONG, SKINNY JEAN
AND THEN PUNKED HER HAIR OUT,
YOU'D BE SAYING,
"WHOO, SHE'S FIERCE."
DIANA.
>> WHEN SHE SMILES
AND WRINKLES UP HER FACE,
I FIND THAT DISTURBING.
I DON'T LIKE THAT.
>> I GOTTA TELL YOU, I AGREE.
I THINK HER SMILE IS SHOCKING.
>> I USED TO SMILE LIKE THIS.
>> LET ME SEE.
>> (laughs)
>> I DON'T REMEMBER YOU...
>> AND I HAD TO LEARN TO, LIKE,
GET A TOP LIP.
YOU CAN'T SMILE TOO HARD.
YOU--YOUR TOP LIP DISAPPEARS,
AND I LEARNED.
JAEL.
>> I KNOW SHE'S HAD SOME
PERSONAL TRAGEDY IN HER LIFE,
BUT THERE'S SO MUCH BAGGAGE
THAT I CAN'T SEE PAST IT.
>> THE HANDS BOTHER ME
IN THIS PHOTOGRAPH,
BUT THE FACE IS BEAUTIFUL.
SO I'M A BIT MIXED UP
ABOUT JAEL.
I'M NOT SURE.
>> FELICIA.
>> I THINK SHE'S VERY BEAUTIFUL.
I DON'T LIKE THIS PHOTOGRAPH
THIS WEEK.
>> SHE'S MANAGED TO NOT CAPTURE
THE LIGHT HER EYES AT ALL,
EVEN THOUGH SHE'S DEAD.
WEEK AFTER WEEK,
SHE'S BEEN RELYING ON US TO SAY,
"HEY, YOU'RE BABY TYRA.
YOU'RE THIS. YOU'RE THAT.
YOU'RE GREAT."
AND I THINK
SHE'S WALKING IN HERE
WITH A COCKINESS THAT THINKS,
"I CAN DO IT.
I DON'T HAVE TO MOVE
IN A PICTURE,"
AND THIS IS WHAT HAPPENS.
>> BRITTANY.
>> THIS IS A GREAT PICTURE.
BUT WHAT WE ALL HAVE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT WAS THE BEAUTY
THAT THESE GIRLS HAVE,
BUT WE NEVER MENTION
HOW THEY'RE ACTUALLY
MAKING THE CLOTHING LOOK.
>> SHE'S MAKING THAT CLOTHES
LOOK KIND OF FIERCE.
WHITNEY.
>> EVEN THOUGH
SHE DOESN'T LOOK DEAD,
I THINK SHE STILL CAME UP
WITH A GREAT PICTURE.
>> SHE DOESN'T LOOK LIKE
A MODEL TO ME,
BUT I HAPPEN TO LOVE
THIS PHOTOGRAPH.
>> SARAH.
>> I THINK SARAH
IS THE CLASSIC EXAMPLE
OF SOMEONE WHO ISN'T ACTUALLY
SORT OF TYPICALLY PRETTY
BUT TRANSLATES AMAZINGLY WELL
ON FILM.
>> JASLENE.
>> JASLENE HAS TAKEN
GREAT SHOT AFTER GREAT SHOT.
>> USUALLY, SHE DISAPPEARS.
>> SHE HAD A PERSONALITY TODAY.
>> YEAH.
>> I WAS HAPPY TO SEE JASLENE
COME IN HERE
WITH A LITTLE OOMPH TODAY.
>> WEEK AFTER WEEK,
SHE'S DONE GREAT PHOTOGRAPHS,
AND THIS IS
A VERY GOOD PHOTOGRAPH.
>> RENEE.
>> THIS IS
MY FAVORITE PHOTOGRAPH.
AND SHE JUST
JUMPS OUT OF THAT LINE TO ME.
I LOVE HER. I THINK SHE'S GREAT.
>> I THINK RENEE DOES PHOTOGRAPH
A LITTLE ON THE OLD SIDE.
IT'S STILL A BEAUTIFUL FACE.
>> TODAY WHEN SHE CAME UP--
AND JUST HER FACE
AND JUST HER WHOLE THING...
WAS WORKING.
>> I AGREE.
>> ALL RIGHT,
WE HAVE REACHED A DECISION.
>> TEN OF YOU STAND BEFORE ME,
BUT I ONLY HAVE NINE PHOTOS
IN MY HANDS,
AND THESE NINE PHOTOS
REPRESENT THE GIRLS
THAT ARE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THE FIRST NAME
THAT I'M GOING TO CALL
IS...
RENEE.
YOU'RE SHINING
ALL THE WAY THROUGH
IN PERSON TODAY, INSIDE AND OUT,
AND THIS PHOTO IS PRETTY MUCH
THE JUDGES' FAVORITE.
CONGRATULATIONS.
>> THANK YOU.
>> YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
>> THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
>> YOU'RE WELCOME.
THE NEXT NAME
I'M GOING TO CALL...
NATASHA.
>> OH, MY GOD!
(laughs) I'M SECOND.
>> CONGRATULATIONS.
>> (in Russian) THANK YOU, TYRA.
>> OOH, DUH-DUH-DUH,
WHATEVER YOU JUST SAID. OKAY.
>> (laughs)
>> BRITTANY.
CONSISTENTLY TAKING
ABSOLUTELY BEAUTIFUL PICTURES.
>> THANK YOU.
>> CONGRATULATIONS.
WHITNEY.
CONGRATULATIONS.
>> THANK YOU.
>> JASLENE.
CONGRATULATIONS.
THE NEXT NAME
I'M GOING TO CALL...
JAEL.
>> (gasps) OH, GOD. OKAY.
>> CONGRATULATIONS.
>> THANK YOU.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
DIANA.
>> OH, GOOD LORD.
WHEW.
>> CONGRATULATIONS.
>> THANK YOU.
>> THE NEXT NAME
I'M GOING TO CALL...
SARAH.
CONGRATULATIONS, SARAH.
>> THANK YOU.
>> YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
WILL FELICIA AND DIONNE
PLEASE STEP FORWARD?
I ONLY HAVE ONE PHOTO
IN MY HANDS.
AND THIS PHOTO REPRESENTS
THE GIRL THAT WILL
STILL BE IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
AND THE NAME THAT I DO NOT CALL
MUST IMMEDIATELY
RETURN TO THE HOUSE,
PACK YOUR BELONGINGS
AND GO HOME.
I'LL START WITH YOU, DIONNE.
WHEN YOU COME INTO THIS ROOM,
NO MATTER HOW BEAUTIFUL
YOUR PICTURES ARE,
THE JUDGES WANNA BE INSPIRED
BY WHAT YOU LOOK LIKE.
BECAUSE ALMOST EVERYBODY
HAD A BEAUTIFUL PICTURE
THIS WEEK.
SO THE JUDGES START THINKING
ABOUT OTHER THINGS,
LIKE THE WAY YOU'RE DRESSED
AND HOW YOU PRESENT YOURSELF
OUTSIDE OF THE PHOTOS.
AND THEN WE HAVE FELICIA,
A GIRL THAT CAME IN HERE--
FIRST PHOTO SHOOT, STRONG,
SECOND PHOTO SHOOT, STRONG.
AND THEN THE THIRD ONE...
IT WAS OKAY.
AND THEN THE FOURTH ONE
WAS THE WEAKEST PICTURE
IN THE BUNCH.
AND THE JUDGES START SAYING,
"IS SHE FALLING APART?
CAN SHE HANDLE THE COMPETITION?"
SO WHO GOES HOME?
>> DIONNE.
>> (crying)
>> (whispers) GO GET
YOUR PICTURE.
>> CONGRATULATIONS.
>> THANK YOU.
>> IT'S TIME TO START THINKING
ABOUT YOUR LOOK, DIONNE,
NOT JUST WHEN YOU'RE
IN FRONT OF THE CAMERA.
IT'S SO IMPORTANT,
ESPECIALLY WHEN
EVERYBODY'S PICTURE
STARTS LOOKING GOOD.
YOU DON'T WANT TO LOOK LIKE
THAT GIRL THAT CAME IN
TO AUDITION TO "TOP MODEL."
THIS IS THE FIFTH WEEK.
YOU WANNA SHOW PROGRESSION.
YOU WANNA LOOK LIKE
YOU COULD BE WALKING DOWN PARIS,
DOWN THE STREET,
GOING TO YOUR GO-SEES.
CONGRATULATIONS.
>> THANK YOU.
>> YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
>> (sniffles)
>> COME HERE, FELICIA.
LET ME TELL YOU
WHAT THE JUDGES THINK ABOUT YOU.
THEY THINK YOU ARE SO BEAUTIFUL.
I THINK YOU ARE SO BEAUTIFUL.
AND I SEE A LITTLE RESEMBLANCE,
BUT YOU HAVE A LOOK
THAT IS YOU, TOO.
AND I THINK ONE THING
THAT YOU NEED IS
A LITTLE BIT MORE DEVELOPMENT
TO UNDERSTAND
WHAT HIGH FASHION IS.
SO I DON'T THINK IT'S OVER.
IT'S OVER HERE,
BUT I THINK YOU JUST HAVE
A LOT MORE STUDYING TO DO,
AND YOU'LL GET THERE.
>> OKAY.
GO SAY--GO SAY GOOD-BYE
TO THE GIRLS.
♪♪
>> ALL THE GIRLS--
I'VE BECOME SO ATTACHED TO THEM.
LIKE, THOSE ARE MY SISTERS.
>> (laughs)
>> OH!
>> SEEING THE OTHER GIRLS CRY
WAS... IT MADE ME FEEL GOOD
'CAUSE IT'S LIKE
I HAD AN IMPACT ON THEM
IN SOME KIND OF WAY.
I'M GLAD THAT THEY DID CRY
'CAUSE I'M LIKE,
IF THESE BITCHES DON'T CRY
IF I GET ELIMINATED,
I'M-A BE PISSED. (laughs)
BUT THEY DID, SO IT'S COOL.
I'M SAD BECAUSE I EXPECTED
TO GO FARTHER THAN THIS,
BUT... JUST GOTTA DEAL WITH IT,
YOU KNOW?
EVERYTHING HAPPENS FOR A REASON.
I AM DEFINITELY GONNA
KEEP MODELING.
THAT'S JUST SOMETHING
I HAVE TO KEEP DOING
NO MATTER WHAT HAPPENED HERE.
NOTHING AT ALL IS GONNA KEEP ME
FROM FOLLOWING MY DREAM.
♪♪
>> COMING UP ON
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"...
>> DO YOU REMEMBER?
>> Of course I remember.
>> EVERYTHING?
>> Everything.
>> NATASHA'S HOME LIFE...
>> MEOW.
>> RAISES QUESTIONS.
>> WHEN NATASHA GOT MARRIED,
SHE WAS ONLY 18,
AND HER HUSBAND WAS 40.
>> DAMN!
>> IT'S CREEPY.
>> AND RENEE CONTINUES
TO ALIENATE EVERYONE.
>> DO YOU THINK THAT
THERE'S EVER GONNA BE
A PLUS-SIZE MODEL
ON THE COVER OF "VOGUE"?
>> RENEE, SHUT THE HECK UP.
GET OUT OF MY FACE.